[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en Primera Plana un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco aquí en
Francia donde se acaba de presentar la
llamada madre de toda la reformas la
reforma de las pensiones que relanza
Emanuel Macro nos acompañan para
analizarlo en este estudio lord commetti
periodista independiente especializado
en política bienvenida Hola Gracias
Carlos Beatriz juez corresponsal del
diario el correo aquí en Francia
bienvenida y Rafael Cruz periodista en
el servicio político de la opinión
bienvenido gracias buenas a todos la
reforma de las pensiones el gran desafío
de macron hoy en Primera Plana
[Música]
Bueno pues ya lo saben macron quiere que
los franceses se jubilen con 64 años en
2030 esto supone retrasar dos años la
edad de jubilación desde los 62 actuales
es el punto principal de la Reforma de
las pensiones que el gobierno de macron
justifica para hacer sostenible el
sistema de pensiones dado el
envejecimiento poblacional la reforma ya
fue pospuesta por la pandemia y ahora El
Ejecutivo la relanza intentando Buscar
la complicidad de la derecha moderada y
mostrando cierta flexibilidad con el
diálogo a sabiendas de que la iniciativa
puede provocar un estallido social los
sindicatos muestran Unión en su contra
como no se había visto en mucho tiempo
también la oposición de izquierdas y de
ultraderecha revisemos lo que dice la
prensa wesfrance día de como calificaron
Muchos medios a la jornada del pasado
martes cuando el gobierno presentó su
polémica reforma Liberación Hace un
juego de palabras con la primera
ministra born que saca no el hacha de
guerra sino la edad de guerra retrasando
a 64 la de jubilación una reforma que
une según la coa al frente sindical una
Unión que no se producía desde hace
bastante tiempo Bueno lo consideran que
esta reforma va a condicionar
políticamente este segundo quinquenio de
Incluso como pase macron a la historia
es decir cuando hablamos de la madre de
todas las reformas de esa magnitud de
esa envergadura que le estamos dando
consideran que es así todavía no es
difícil
decirlo pero es cierto que los
macronistas piensan que esta reforma
sería un legado de seriedad de
financiera y de buena gestión del
presupuesto del Estado Pero la realidad
es que es una reforma que me parece en
continuidad con lo que han hecho previos
gobiernos de izquierda o de derecha en
Francia o sea alargar
alargar la dureza de cotización o
aplazar la edad legal de jubilación no
es como una reforma muy Revolucionaria
tipo macron Style
Beatriz la madre de todas las reformas
Sí bueno la llaman aquí Así se hace
gracia cuando lo dicen no pero es un
poco
de verdad no porque impacta de una forma
que a lo mejor no impactan otro tipo de
un poco aquí en Francia que es un poco
como el día de la marmota O la película
está atrapados en el tiempo que yo llevo
cinco años aquí y llevamos casi 5 años
hablando cada vez de la Reforma de las
pensiones y siempre la el temor de las
movilizaciones de las protestas
Pero bueno si lo ves desde España ahora
en España se jubila la gente a 60
66 creo que es este año entonces que los
franceses se vayan a jubilar a 64 Pues
nos parece incluso Pues un chollo no
Comparado con se ve como un privilegio
desde estos puntos de Europa Es verdad
que también la perspectiva francesa es
otra es de precisamente porque salimos a
la calle conseguimos salvaguardar ese
estado de bienestar se puede ver desde
las perspectivas y luego también es
diferente por ejemplo en España 66 años
con 37 años años de cotización aquí en
Francia sería 64 con 43 años de
cotización
Bueno al final se compensa una cosa con
la otra no los años de cotización y
alargamiento Pero bueno Comparado con
España los españoles pensarían de que se
quejan los franceses con 64 Rafael la
máxima del gobierno es su justificación
hay que trabajar más para hacer
sostenible el sistema dado el
envejecimiento de la población
Aparentemente nos parece una lógica Pero
esto es discutible esta premisa en la
que se basa es discutible y se discute
mucho Sobre todo desde la oposición de
izquierda
por ejemplo estamos ahora con esa edad
de jubilación de los legal a los 62 años
pero por ejemplo la izquierda que ya
está unida en el parlamento desde las
últimas elecciones propone la vuelta a
los 60 años como como ya estaba en los
en los años 80 la justificación del
gobierno no solo es que vivimos más
tiempo el gobierno pone el enfoque sobre
el sistema de financiación y él dice que
sí que ahora el sistema es estable pero
que dentro de 5 o 10 o 15 años hay que
asegurar la
pues la buena salud del sistema y
garantizar las futuras pensiones y ahí
está el debate entre de economistas unos
que dicen que hay que hacer esta reforma
ahora para que dé sus frutos dentro de
unos cinco o diez años y otros más desde
la izquierda que dicen que hay otras
soluciones que se pueden encontrar otras
medidas y otras formas de financiar el
sistema Pero que no hay urgencia
Entonces yo creo que el debate ahora
desde el punto de vista económico al
menos está entre esas dos visiones de
qué urgente es esa reforma hay que
hacerla ya o Podemos esperar unos años
urgentes la reforma Lo cierto es que
macron lo llevaba como promesa electoral
cuando se fue reelegido el año pasado
esto legitima este hecho legitima que
siga adelante con este tema otra vez hay
debate que por supuesto la oposición y
principalmente de izquierda dice que
macron cierto fue electo pero frente a
Main lo pen entonces mucha gente muchas
veces votaron para él pero para para
echar a pen y también
vuelta entonces
deslegitimearíamos siempre al que al que
sale del elegido como presidente porque
siempre diríamos que la han escogido
como menos malo Entonces no llevaríamos
a cabo nada complicado y otro otro punto
es que después con elecciones
legislativas perdió la mayoría absoluta
en el parlamento O sea que la oposición
dice que macron no es tan legítimo para
implementar esta Promesa de campaña pero
y sus partisanes seguramente dicen que
sí que fue electo para justamente
digamos la buena salud garantizar la
buena salud de nuestro sistema de
pensiones recordemos que esta reforma
quedó aplazada por el impacto de la
crisis sanitaria de la covid otra crisis
precedente la de los amarillos en el
primer quinquenio puso contra las
cuerdas el presidente no sé si estos
movimientos sociales como los paros
sectoriales que hemos visto hasta hace
poco hacen que el gobierno vaya con más
pies de plomo a la hora de plantear la
Reforma ahora Beatriz Sí porque las
manifestaciones de los chalecos
amarillos pusieron un poco en jaque la
presidencia de macrón hay con esto no me
extraña que también lo sufrimos nosotros
cubriendo las manifestaciones todos los
sábados que íbamos y luego también hay
que recordar que cuando lo intentó en
2019-2020 que antes de la justo antes de
que empezara la pandemia hubo un mes de
huelga de transportes que eso también se
puede repetir otra vez O sea que ellos
intentan ir con piel de plomo y también
durante la campaña macron había hablado
de 65 años ahora al final han quedado
propuesto 64 yo creo que para no ser tan
brutal y no hacer
que más gente salga a la calle no decir
mira yo os haya puesto 65 pero soy muy
bueno y ahora
propongo 64 la novedad es que enfrente
se encuentra con una Unión sindical
Rafael que no se producía desde hace
muchísimo tiempo en Francia y que se va
a plasmar en las calles el próximo
jueves día 19 es verdad Y eso pesa que
el gobierno intentó durante muchas
semanas muchos meses convencer a los
sindicatos más moderados más moderados o
reformistas como la sevdt por ejemplo
pero no lo consiguió porque como decía
antes
muchos de estos sindicatos incluido los
reformistas no creen en esa urgencia y y
piden tiempo para negociar una reforma
que para ellos Sería más más justa pero
claro ese frente sin aludido es una
amenaza para el proyecto del gobierno
porque claro hemos visto que en los
transportes en al público hay muchos los
funcionarios pueden movilizar bastante
sobre todo porque ahora están en una
estrategia de pues clásica digamos no de
manifestaciones de huelgas etcétera En
la que el gobierno sabe moverse más o
menos estábamos hablando de los chalecos
amarillos porque esto preocupa más al
gobierno es que el gobierno sabe
enfrentar a los sindicatos a la
oposición política porque estamos en un
marco clásico pero el desbordamiento que
supondría el nuevos movimientos tipo
chaleco amarillo esto no lo maneja y no
sabe gestionar nadie y mucho menos el
gobierno entonces ojo porque claro el
frente sindical
estamos en una batalla clásica pero el
amenaza del desbordamiento siempre está
ahí no el próximo jueves los sindicatos
anuncian esa gran movilización o frente
a la reforma de las la amplitud que
pueda tener la cita del próximo jueves
es lo que va a definir la el juego de
cartas en futuro en esta reforma sí
pienso que va a dar como una prima una
primera Perdón primer el primer impulso
y Tendremos que ver Cuántas personas van
a manifestar si los sectores claves se
van a movilizar como los transportes los
combustibles
a partir de ahí o si se consigue
Desactivar ese frente que sería muy
interesante para el gobierno no pero sí
cierto que el gobierno bueno olvidé de
El portavoz del gobierno ha dicho que no
cree que va a haber una movilización
masiva pero creo que en realidad si van
a mirar con mucho cuidado las cifras de
este jueves después de lo que llevamos
hay un riesgo de que los a los
sindicatos les cueste movilizar el
próximo jueves y precisamente que con
ello esté jugando el gobierno Beatriz
yo creo que no porque aquí yo siempre
digo que aquí en Francia es hacer Mario
protestar es el deporte nacional y se
manifiestan siempre o sea que cualquier
excusa es buena para manifestarse
entonces imagino que sobre todo si si
los profesores van a la huelga los
padres tienen que quedar en casa cuidar
a los niños Si no hay transporte se
tienen que aunque no se vayan a la calle
a manifestar mucha gente parte del país
quedará paralizado No es cierto que en
las encuestas sale que una mayoría de
los franceses Están en contra de esta
reforma pero al mismo tiempo también el
gobierno puede jugar con un cansancio no
de los franceses cuneros y donde salir a
las calles y también de las huelgas y de
los paros que han sufrido los francés en
otoño no Rafael Bueno hay dos cosas de
tu pregunta la primera es que es cierto
que los sondeos indican que los
franceses no quieren trabajar más no
quieren trabajar más tiempo pero al
mismo tiempo los mismos sondeos
muestran que pues los franceses tienen
sentimientos contradictorios Porque
también una mayoría de franceses dicen
que bueno hay que hacer algo para saber
guardar al sistema porque sabemos que
hay una cuestión demográfica está ahí Y
tampoco se puede negar no
luego pues está el el la postura del
gobierno que es típico típica perdón de
los gobiernos de derecha Y de cierta
forma es el líder de la derecha francesa
es dividida pero para mucha gente es el
líder de la derecha y para los líderes
de derecha esa postura de El Líder
político que se mantiene firme frente a
los sindicatos que quieren impedir el
cambio Es algo que para su electorado
siempre ha funcionado Entonces
el problema es que dónde está la mayoría
no la mayoría está con nos indica todo
está con él esa parte de los franceses
que quieren cambio que como tú decías
se sienten cansados no por la repetición
de las huelgas que entiendo que desde el
extranjero se ve como deporte nacional
pero yo quiero decir que la gente no
sale en la calle porque le da la Porque
le da la gana no es porque hay mucha
gente en ese país no quiere estar
reforma no solo los sindicatos no solo
trabajadores pero los franceses no los
franceses de apio Entonces es una
carrera y este tipo de conflicto siempre
es una carrera y Cuanto más tiempo dure
pues veremos Dónde dónde recae la grasa
no vamos a seguir hablando de este pulso
va a ser a vuelta de pausa que en
Primera Plana hasta ahora
sarajevo Managua Bali ciudades que como
tantas otras han sufrido la guerra el
hambre La dictadura o catástrofes
naturales
24 vuelve a las regiones que marcaron la
actualidad internacional
sus habitantes cuentan su nueva vida sus
esperanzas y su lucha para superar un
pasado traumático
acompáñenme en boleto de vuelta Todas
las semanas por France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]
France 24 la economía día a día
Lite actualite seguimos en Primera Plana
esta semana hablando de la Reforma de
las pensiones aquí en Francia bautizada
como la madre de todas las reformas que
ha relanzado Emmanuel macron un proyecto
que fue abandonado antes de la crisis
sanitaria pero recordemos que ahora ha
relanzado la semana que viene el jueves
19 hay una movilización sindical vamos a
ver la magnitud que tiene antes de la
pausa hablábamos precisamente con Rafael
de ese pulso de cómo se va a establecer
entre el gobierno y los sindicatos lo
hacemos con lord commetti periodista
independiente Beatriz juez corresponsal
del correo y Rafael Cruz periodista en
el servicio político de la opinión Lo
cierto es que 62 años es una de las
edades más temporadas de Europa
actualmente la edad jubilación en
Francia está en 62 el gobierno
recordemos quiere retrasarle a 64 en
2030 log hay que entender esto como un
privilegio para los franceses porque es
verdad que desde fuera de Francia el
resto de países de Europa ven la edad de
jubilación francesa actual como un
privilegio bueno Es cierto que en
Francia la edad de jubilación es una de
las más bajas de Europa pero no es la
más creo en Polonia para las mujeres de
60 años en Suecia es 62 años
y también hay que ver la duración de
cotización obviamente y la esperanza de
vida en buena salud pero el debate
también es que tal vez trabajamos menos
Y tenemos mejor salud mejor condiciones
de vida o porque vivimos más viejos
Tendremos que trabajar más tiempo esto
es un debate un poco filosófico
se extraen las consecuencias para
establecer una reforma de pensiones de
un lado o de otro
Sí bueno es ese justo es la clave no es
si hay que trabajar
más porque vivimos más y Porque no
tenemos también otros factores porque no
hay no tenemos no hay tantos niños que
nacen Entonces no hay tantos
trabajadores Entonces otro factor clave
no Porque ahora la gente tiene uno antes
A lo mejor tenía cinco hijos Ahora tiene
uno entonces es el gran debate no y no
hay una respuesta
si seguimos con la lógica el
envejecimiento de la población Va a
continuar Va a continuar Va a continuar
luego vamos a hacer otra reforma de las
pensiones luego a 70 años luego a 80
años y a lo mejor llegará un punto en el
que tenemos que replantear un poco el
cuadro en sí es decir los elementos del
concepto que tenemos de trabajo algo más
genérico que estar siempre con esa misma
lógica no sé Rafael bueno Es verdad que
la demografía y el hecho de que vivimos
más tiempo es un indicador pero no es el
único por ejemplo desde la oposición la
izquierda de los sindicatos ellos
presentan otro indicador que es la
esperanza de vida en buena salud Porque
una cosa es llegar a los 70-75 pero otra
cosa es llegar a partir a partir de los
60 años la gente pues tiene más
problemas de salud que antes y
si entramos en el terreno filosófico lo
que propone la oposición que quieras por
ejemplo es
gozar de esa edad no no de de llegar a
los 65 o 70 años pero tener tiempo para
disfrutarlo no
Es verdad que hay un problema entre el
número de activos de gente que está
trabajando y esa masa de jubilados que
va a llegar por el problema demográfico
que tenemos pero luego claro es la
cohesión es si el sistema está
financiado si no hay amenazas sobre
el dinero es que va a haber para pagar
las pensiones Por qué tendríamos que
trabajar más tiempo ese es el problema y
luego claro los economistas tienen que
debatir más y y decirnos cuál es la
respuesta correcta la izquierda y la
ultraderecha batallan por liderar la
oposición y la confrontación a esta
reforma se antoja fundamental Quizá el
punto discordante es que los franceses
también esperan propuestas de cómo ellos
van a ser sostenible el sistema de las
pensiones no sé si los haces también
piensan que no vale el no a todo por
parte de la oposición log bueno Esto
siempre ha sido un poco el desafío para
bajo los mandatos de Cancún Cómo existir
Y cómo salir un poco de la oposición
sistemática y proponer cosas concretas
a la izquierda ya ha dicho que va a ser
filibustero en el departamento o sea
proponer miles y miles de enmiendas para
bloquear un poco el texto Pero esto no
será suficiente para para realmente
impedir que la reforma pase
probablemente y del lado las propuestas
bueno como ha dicho Rafael la izquierda
propone un poco como un debate digamos
más filosófico la izquierda también
propone aumentar las tasas las
cotizaciones y como una participación
mayor de las empresas para no penalizar
a los trabajadores dice y del lado
imagino ven no es tan claro su posición
O sea que propondría el pulmón nacional
para las pensiones no es muy claro
lo complicado es salir y presentar algo
como un impuesto por pero la alternativa
más creíble de la propuesta a una sería
decir nosotros proponemos un impuesto
Pero eso también erosión a políticamente
salir a decir eso no Beatriz no quiere
hacerlo porque ya prometió en campaña
que no iba que no iba a subir los
impuestos entonces Esa no es la
alternativa que hay y de todas formas
seguro que si propusiesen
subir los impuestos a la izquierda
saldría la calle diciendo que
macrón
ha incumplido su promesa electoral O sea
que
la reforma también recoge algunas
excepciones que el gobierno habría hecho
a los republicanos para ganarse su apoyo
parlamentario en la derecha moderada
como el hecho de que aquellos que
comenzaron a trabajar antes de los 20
años puedan jubilarse entre los 58 y los
62 y que ciertos colectivos bueno los
militares bomberos policías escapen a la
regla Rafael el apoyo de los
republicanos es clave en toda esta
historia bueno es clave porque el
Gobierno no tiene mayoría absoluta en la
asamblea nacional entonces necesita
votos de otros grupos los comentarios
para votarla así de simple y también yo
creo que hay Otro aspecto un poco más
largo que es la relación de con la
derecha no sabemos hemos visto como el
partido los dos partidos tradicionales
habían sido aplastados por la victoria
de Majo en el 2017 el partido socialista
lo sufrió bastante esos últimos años
pero parece que ahora le toca la derecha
no porque parece un poco difícil para
los líderes conservadores o poner esa
Macro o explicar a sus lectores que no
hay que votar a manco y votar a ellos
porque
en realidad si lo miramos bien lo que
propone makomo es el programa
tradicional de la derecha y esa reforma
de manera muy específica él ese partido
pedía esa reforma
claro Hay un par de detalles que dan
cosas por discutir pero en ese momento
Parece que pues la derecha lo tiene todo
para votar no es muy complicado la
posición de los republicanos en esta
reforma es complicado existir con moneda
de identidad identidad propia perdón y
pero
no necesita realmente los republicanos
para votar la reforma lo puede hacer Sin
ellos pero me parece que sería un
símbolo políticamente un poco malo pero
porque pasar una reforma un poco dura
digamos de austeridad financiera solo
sin el apoyo de ningún partido sería un
poco
no muy positivo para su imagen de líder
político me parece Porque qué supondría
un fracaso de de forma para macron
Beatriz después de toda la que se ha
liado
Pues yo diría que bueno macron es una de
las propuestas que hizo la primera
legislatura es la propuesta clave de
todas las que de todas las reformas que
ha propuesto
que se juega el legado político verdad
el legado político es igual que cuando
yo que sé es hotter hizo su reforma de
la seguridad social también
en esa época había muchas protestas en
Alemania pero pero al final Merkel se
benefició después de esas protestas no
que buenos años de Bonanza gracias a eso
esto puede pasar igual puede ser que a
lo mejor pase como el malo de la
película porque se ha hecho trabajar
hasta los 64 años a los franceses pero
que después yo que sé en 20 años pues le
agradezca namia gracias a esa reforma
pudimos salvar el sistema de las
pensiones No lo sé si ocurrirá o no
Desde un punto ya más desde el punto de
vista más cultural o filosófico no sé si
creen que falta en todo este debate un
replanteamiento general del concepto
trabajo como actividad humana de lo que
esperamos de él y de Cuándo es digno o
deja de serlo Para nuestras vidas Rafael
no sé si sabe falta algo en falta en el
debate o no Yo creo que está ahí pero lo
yo creo que hemos entrado en el en ese
debate más desde la perspectiva de la
desigualdad no porque claro otros
aspectos del debate es que no es lo
mismo jubilarse para una persona que
empezó a trabajar con 16 años en
trabajos manuales duros y trabajos más
intelectuales o gente que bueno Después
de estudios superiores empezó a trabajar
con 27 28 años todo el mundo entiende de
que bueno
haciendo un trabajo manual jubilarse a
los 70 años no tiene tiene poco sentido
entonces y también la los jóvenes las
generaciones más más jóvenes tienen una
percepción del trabajo bastante distinta
a la de otras generaciones en las que a
lo mejor el oficio la profesión definía
más a no y ahora hay una búsqueda de
sentido mucho más fuerte entre las
nuevas generaciones que no creen en la
Pues en el que el sistema de pensiones
seguirá activo cuando ellos se jubilen
también es Otro aspecto del del debate
Los jóvenes no creen en la jubilación
Ellos están no todos Claro pero hay esa
percepción de que ellos no podrán
jubilarse
tiene esa percepción de que falte algo
más desde el punto de vista cultural o
filosófico en el debate público estos
días creo como lo Allí se puede escuchar
un poco de discusiones más filosóficas o
más intelectuales sobre el tema del
trabajo pero lo que pasa es que el
sistema de las pensiones es tan complejo
y como un poco opaco que a veces el
debate se enfoca en puntos muy técnicos
no sé cómo el punto de las pensiones el
índice no sé qué y eso es muy muy
complicado y para hablando de la
movilización movilización en las calles
lo que será muy interesante ver
agradecer a la movilización de los
jóvenes porque lo como Azael hoy muchos
jóvenes no van a salir a la calle para
defender un sistema de pensión Que bueno
que no les interesa hoy en día y piensan
que en unas décadas capaz que no existe
más entonces eso es un tema que me
parece muy interesante como los jóvenes
se van a posicionar
sí Bueno hay que siempre es el debate
decía hay que
trabajar para
trabajar para trabajar es un es el gran
debate no menos impulsa hacer keiko y
que defendemos sí sí sí debate
filosófico cultural y que a veces se nos
escapa no nos quedamos en el punto en el
salario en el euro en la edad y se nos
escapa un debate a lo mejor más de fondo
sí que es como decía El antes y hay que
trabajar para poder jubilarse muchos
años para poder jubilarse bien o que
Cuál es el debate no y bueno no sé si
hay una respuesta para ello pero no lo
sé pero yo añadiría que en Francia la
jubilación se ve como un derecho social
o sea el fruto de conquistas sociales
también está ahí todo eso es muy
importante la imaginación acerca de las
de las luces Por eso vemos cómo se
reactiva no con los sindicatos en la
izquierda porque pelear por las
pensiones para la izquierda francesa es
como es más que cultural es identitario
no es que entonces también en sí
entramos en ahí movemos un montón de
cosas que no son estrictamente
económicas o políticas pero también
tocan a la parte más humana de cada uno
Claro pues muchísimas gracias y un
placer hablar con ustedes Beatriz Rafael
y log del iba a decir del debate de que
está hoy mismo en la calle del debate de
la Reforma de las pensiones que nos
afecta a todos Aunque yo creo que más
bien en la calle en las cafeterías el
debate que esta es la canción de Shakira
con pique Pero bueno hoy hemos hablado
de ello del debate de las pensiones
Muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes y
nosotros nos vemos aquí en Primera Plana
la próxima semana Muchas gracias
[Música]